even if you live in a dark room
containing more empty pizza boxes than a
Domino's branch you can still live in
the lap of luxury if you have enough
dollars in your GTA bank account any
player with more than 1 million in GTA
money in that maze bank account can
choose to become a VIP do that you can
make a name for your own organization
and higher up to three other players as
your bodyguards VIP players can give
bodyguards animal vehicles including the
new turreted limo VIPs can also utilize
a service called ghost organization
which temporarily removes your entire
organization from the GamesRadar new
game types have also been detailed
hostile takeover and unknown package is
held within a restricted area and
organizations compete to collect the
package and deliver it to a set location
asset recovery sends your organization
to LSP d stations around the city to
recover impounded vehicles piracy
prevention is an attack and defense on
the decks of a luxurious super yacht
defending players born in the all
attacking players on offshore with
access to boats executive deathmatch
puts organizations in rival deathmatch
style battles inside a free mode most
once it makes all the players inside an
organization have a five star wanted
level with a countdown of ten minutes
and the last player alive wins the
challenge market manipulation place at
erase from store to store and a hold of
styles free to collect as much money as
possible autobio players must steal and
deliver as many vehicles as they can and
other features include 10 new stilt
houses which are now for sale around
vinewood Hills each equipped with a
ten-car garage and a heist planning room
so you still living the gangster
lifestyle in GTA 5 well the new array of
Hyrule of features be enough to get you
back into the game let us know in the
comments section below or you can find
me on Twitter at irregular Dave and for
your GTA 5 News keep it on gamespot com